so 2007
and and and you're not forget about just
three number one
you were 21. right yeah oh damn
and you were not it wasn't just three
number one hits you were on [ __ ]
everything i mean yeah you were on every
and absolutely this is like the
auto-tune thing
yeah like you were like the share did it
first and then you made it real
really good it was a real it was a real
so
yeah it was a real thing by dan and then
auto-tune kind of became the norm
yeah and people started criticizing you
for bringing that to the table
and then as a result of like jay-z
coming out and
attacking you does that have something
to do with why
things cooled off for you i don't i you
know what
um it came to it it was
the craziest coincidence of time like
right before jay-z came out with death
of auto-tune
uh my managers were like dude you're on
a [ __ ] thousand songs we gotta stop
right now we gotta stop nobody's getting
features
nobody's doing anything we just need to
get you out of the media
for at least like some months and then
right after that jay-z was like boom
death of auto-tune
and we didn't plan this but i mean we
planned our
uh break so my managers were like dude
you need to disappear for a minute
and right after that you're overexposed
and then right after that jay-z dropped
death of monotone
and it looks like a diss track it looks
like a diss track jay-z
dropped the joint and then i disappeared
oh [ __ ]
so it was just like [ __ ] and what year
was that
this was like eight nine yeah this is
like
eight nine and then so bro like my
managers was like
dude you gotta just calm down you're on
too much [ __ ] you're overexposed you
gotta stop and i was like you know what
that makes sense a month later jay-z
drops
death of auto tune and it looks like he
made me disappear
right so you went after him
i went after him a little bit it was
like i was
i was uh this is one of the recovery
stories
i was just so drunk at a show in vegas
and i was doing um i was doing a daytime
pool party
and uh you know this was right after
depth of autotune
and people were in the crowd like jay-z
killed you
like it was just like jay-z shut you
down and i'm like no
you don't understand you know you don't
have time to explain
right you know what i'm saying so it's
just like [ __ ] you
so it was just a whole bunch of [ __ ] and
and and
that came out as t-pain is
attacking jay-z and i'm like no i just
i was doing a show and everybody was
like dynasty [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm like [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
it was just like it was so much [ __ ] man
it just came out
as that whole thing and yeah so then did
that inspire
uh or jay-z to come again
no no no no no no i mean the the crazy
thing is
what i found out after that was jay-z
was never talking about me in the first
place
so he was he was talking about rappers
doing the [ __ ] like he was talking about
rappers copying
me and he was like kind of
low-key like defending me all right and
then i took it the wrong way and it was
like oh that's [ __ ] embarrassing
[Laughter]
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats